hoy es vengo a hablar de la mutilación
genital femenina
si cogemos la definición dada por la
organización mundial de la salud veremos
que la mutilación genital femenina
comprende todos los procedimientos
consistentes en la resección parcial o
total de los genitales externos
femeninos así como otras lesiones a los
órganos genitales por razones no médicas
200 millones de mujeres han sufrido la
mutilación genital femenina y si nada
cambia de aquí a 2030 habrá 68 millones
más está reconocido internacionalmente
como una violación de los derechos
humanos de la mujer y de la niña y no
tiene ningún tipo de beneficio para la
salud
si esta misma pregunta se lo hacemos a
mujeres que han sufrido mutilación
genital femenina seguramente no te sepan
dar una definición literal
para ellas es simplemente el deber y la
responsabilidad de mantener se apura sin
saber realmente por qué no se preguntan
si es porque se practica o si se puede
llegar a parar
para muchas otras es un recuerdo muy
doloroso que prefiero no hablar de ello
porque las hace revivir el momento en
que todo cambio para ellas el día en que
pasaron de ser niñas felices a tener una
infancia triste
y aún conviven con esas consecuencias
emocionales y psicológicas a día de hoy
mujeres que sufrieron la mutilación
genital femenina en el momento en que se
les practica tienen consecuencias
físicas inmediatas como pueden ser
hemorragias infecciones o un dolor que
puede llevar a ese estado de shock pero
lo que ninguna de esas mujeres se
imaginaba es que ese dolor físico
continuaría a lo largo de toda su vida
hasta el día que se hacen adultas y
hasta el día que mucho
mueran
cada vez que van a orinar y sienten
dolor se debe a que las mutilaron cada
vez que les baja la menstruación y
sienten un dolor insoportable se debe a
que las mutilaron
su falta de apetito sexual se debe a que
las mutilaron y en la gran mayoría de
las veces los problemas que tienen
durante el embarazo y el parto se debe a
que las mutilaron nadie les explica que
lo que les pasó a los cinco años de edad
es lo que les causa sufrimiento a día de
hoy
mujeres que sobrevivieron a la
mutilación genital femenina cuentan que
lo que les pasó a ellas fue un atentado
contra su vida contra la mujer un
atentado a su sexualidad a nuestra
sexualidad en definitiva un atentado
hacia la vida muchas de ellas cuentan
que tuvieron mucho miedo a que tras
haber sido cortadas y cosidas esa herida
se volviese a abrir y que las tuvieran
que cortar y coser de nuevo por eso
hacen todo lo posible por mantenerse
quietas hasta que las heridas cierran y
cicatrizan
para todas esas mujeres que no han
sobrevivido a la mutilación genital
femenina que no forman parte de ese
recuento de mujeres mutiladas la
mutilación genital femenina ha
significado para ella su sentencia de
muerte
si preguntamos a la sociedad y tomamos a
españa como ejemplo de sociedad
occidental seguramente una gran mayoría
no comprenda exactamente lo que es la
mutilación genital femenina y se
dediquen a juzgar y a criticar desde una
posición de superioridad como si los que
lo practican fueran salvajes bárbaros o
simplemente ignorantes otra gran parte
desconoce que existe esta práctica y
sólo conocen prefieren efectivamente
creer que no que es una práctica salvaje
que no las afecta ni las incumbe a ellas
si tomamos a malasia como ejemplo de
país es el propio gobierno el ministerio
de salud que ofrece una guía específica
donde limita su práctica a los médicos
es decir que el gobierno permite a los
médicos practicar el tipo 1 de
mutilación genital femenina el país que
os hablo es malasia
que hay mucha población musulmana y
seguramente muchas personas del mundo
occidental condenen y digan que hay que
prohibirlo
pero qué pasa si se practica en clínicas
privadas europeas
lo cierto es que cada vez hay más
mujeres que acuden a clínicas privadas
aquí en europa para conseguir una
reducción de sus labios y gran parte de
las veces se debe al para sentirse más
bellas para que nos quede claro si se
practica en una aldea remota por
personas que no han ido al colegio es
algo horrible y tenemos que pararlo pero
si se practica en una clínica lo dejamos
pasar ese es el mensaje que lanzamos
cuando dejamos que se normalicen su
práctica en clínicas
tenemos que conseguir y prohibir toda
forma de presión social que nos obligue
a someternos a procedimientos que no son
beneficiosas para nuestra propia salud
si me preguntáis a mí qué es la
mutilación genital femenina o seré
sincera nunca me lo he planteado desde
el lado personal es fácil y las charlas
a conferencias y entrevistas y dar la
definición global de la mutilación
genital femenina y contar que existen
cuatro tipos de mutilación genital
femenina que lo practican tanto
cristianos como musulmanes que no
depende del estatus social que uno tiene
que la religión no lo avala que lo
practican desde edades muy tempranas
como puede ser la etapa lactante a
edades tardías que la ley no es la única
vía y que por supuesto hay muchas cosas
por hacer es fácil hablar de todo esto
sin entrar en algo tan personal como qué
es la mutilación genital femenina para
mí
soy una mujer somalí nació mogadishu
capital de somalia para las que no los
tengan ubicado en el mapa somalia está
en el cuerno de áfrica es un país
costero y hay muchas cosas que os podría
contar de este país donde yo nací y no
todos de ellos malos pero el dato más
importante que nos trae hoy aquí es que
el 98 por ciento de las mujeres en
somalia han sido mutiladas el 98 por
ciento un país donde no está mal visto
llevar a cabo esta práctica sino al
contrario es motivo de orgullo y honor
que a tu hija la corte que la purifique
en un país donde no existe una ley que
lo prohíba o que lo condene en ese país
nací yo
a mi madre la mutilaron a los 5 años de
edad y todas las mujeres de mi familia
también fueron mutiladas yo en cambio no
he sido mutilada fui una niña afortunada
y pude salvarme de esa purificación
porque mi madre antepuso mi vida y mis
necesidades a las presiones y
obligaciones sociales
para mí la mutilación genital femenina
es pasado presente y futuro es pasado
porque ya no va a haber más mujeres en
mi familia que vayan a ser mutiladas y
el árbol genealógico de las mujeres de
mi familia se vuelve a crear con mujeres
fuertes libres dueñas de su cuerpo y de
su destino es presente porque hay mucho
camino por recorrer y tenemos que
hacerlo juntas y de la mano tenemos que
conseguir que más mujeres como mi madre
quieran cambiar su destino y la de sus
hijas tenemos que unirnos todas y todos
para crear un mundo donde todas seamos
libres de elegir
y es parte de mi futuro porque por cada
niña y cada mujer no mutilada toda una
generación futura se habrá salvado
os preguntaréis
por qué es tan difícil erradicar esta
práctica hay muchos factores que llevan
a que sea algo complejo la cultura la
religión preservar la virginidad los
tabúes entre otras cosas cuando algo
forma parte de tu cultura
termina siendo parte de tu identidad
rechazar algo que está tan arraigada
profundamente significa o al menos eso
piensan muchas negar una parte de ti soy
partidaria de defender todo lo bueno que
tenga la cultura de una persona pero no
podemos permitir que se aprovechan de la
cultura para hacer daño físico y
psicológico lo que daña no es bueno para
nadie
la religión ha servido de escudo para
justificar cosas que de ninguna otra
manera tendrían justificación
qué persona en su sano juicio iría
contra su propio dios nadie
no obstante no hay ninguna parte de la
biblia el corán o torá donde se cite que
a una mujer haya que mutilar la pero
gran mayoría de las personas que lo
practican creen que su deber religioso y
lanzó la pregunta a todas las mujeres
que me escuchan hoy hasta cuándo vamos a
permitir que usen la religión para
hacernos daño hasta cuándo vamos a
permitir que se use la religión para
mantener esta desigualdad existente en
todas las sociedades
este año me regalaron un libro que se
titula el himen y el hiyab es de la
escritora mona él javi un capítulo que
me resultó fascinante es el que habla
del dios de la virginidad y el deseo que
tenemos todas musulmanas cristianas
ateas de venerar a ese dios de la
virginidad muchos de los sufrimientos
que padecemos ha sido para preservar
intacto nuestro himen por asegurar
nuestra virginidad ponemos en riesgo la
integridad física de las niñas el
derecho al placer de las mujeres y
nuestro derecho a exigir justicia cuando
hay algún tipo de violencia sexual la
virginidad de la mujer ha sido es y
siempre será centro de debate de todas
las sociedades existe un esfuerzo en
todos los niveles por asegurar que
mantengamos nuestra virginidad intacta
para mí relacionar la virginidad con la
pureza y la honestidad es la mayor
estafa que el ser humano ha creado en la
cultura somalí y por desgracia muchas
culturas se considera que una mujer
mutilada es garantía de virginidad y de
fidelidad os imagináis la presión de una
mujer desde que nace a ser perfecta y
que esa perfección empiece y acabe con
su virginidad en cambio el hombre es
libre de ser y de sentir
quiero que imaginemos que por un momento
una mujer consigue huir de toda esa
presión social y no llega a ser a tener
ese estándar de mujer ideal y consigue
ejercer su derecho a la sexualidad como
ella quiera pasaría de cara a su familia
a ser una mujer rebelde una [ __ ] una
cualquiera ahora imaginaros a un hombre
que también decides expresar su
sexualidad como él quiere creéis que le
llamarían rebelde [ __ ] inmoral creéis
que le mutilar ian para asegurar su
virginidad no porque la integridad y la
pureza los hombres no se mide por su
virginidad sino por sus capacidades qué
pasaría si nuestra existencia como
mujeres también se midiera por nuestras
capacidades
una mujer virgen o no tiene derecho a
elegir sobre su vida y sobre su cuerpo
no podemos permitir que nos pongan en un
ideal de mujer que no debería haber
existido desde un principio
y como todo el sistema de opresión como
toda dictadura que necesita ocultar sus
crímenes el silencio es su mejor arma si
nadie habla de ello si nadie lo critica
así nadie puede expresar libremente lo
que cree que está mal no habría una
ciamiento no habría una protesta y todo
continuaría como debe continuar y es por
ello que todo lo relacionado a nosotras
se nos educa a ocultarlo y a guardarlo
para nosotras se nos dice y no siempre
de forma tan directa a no hablar sobre
un tema o un comportamiento concreto
tachándolo casi siempre de inapropiado
indebido inoportuno
cómo podemos acabar con la mutilación
genital femenina si ni siquiera podemos
hablar de la existencia de su práctica
como pueden los gobiernos que prohíben
la mutilación genital femenina ayudar a
acabar con ellos y ni siquiera admiten
que siguen pasando en su país
mi madre y mi tía ambas supervivientes
de la mutilación genital femenina no se
sentaron a hablar de lo que les pasó
hasta que ambas fueron adultas hasta que
ambos fueran madres y esposas como es
posible que un hecho tan decisivo en la
vida de una persona no sea tema de
conversación
hay miedo hay mucho miedo a que las
mujeres digamos en voz alta
todo lo que soportan en cada rincón del
mundo porque todo el sistema de opresión
hacia nosotras corre peligro porque
saben que nuestro silencio es su mejor
arma y que nuestra voz es nuestra mejor
alma cada vez que callamos el sistema
patriarcal gana cada vez que alzamos
nuestra voz el camino hacia la justicia
y la igualdad da un paso hacia adelante
es así de simple
qué podemos hacer para ayudar a acabar
con la mutilación genital femenina y con
las desigualdades existentes en todas
partes del mundo no podemos buscar
excusas no podemos ser indiferentes no
es una opción tenemos que asegurar que
más mujeres quieran contar su historia
tenemos que ser apoyo y asegurar que su
voz nuestra voz se escucha porque
nuestra voz importa
tenemos que recordar y tener muy
presentes que el fin último de la
mutilación genital femenina es preservar
la virginidad para luego casar los
hay que educar a la sociedad y no hablo
son las sociedades donde se practica la
mutilación hay que decir en voz alta y
dejar claro que nuestra razón de ser no
es casarnos casarse no es una obligación
sino una elección es fácil quizá para mí
o para vosotras porque no se han educado
de esta manera pero hay muchas partes
del mundo donde no hay ninguna otra
alternativa
todo esto será posible cuando se empiece
a desvincular y que la virginidad de la
mujer sea una elección también personal
y no impuesta por una presión social
os animo a todos ya todas que
investiguen un poco más sobre la
mutilación genital femenina que
preguntéis amigas que creéis que lohan
lo han tenido y nos preguntáis a
nosotras porque el primer paso para
acabar con la mutilación genital
femenina es el conocimiento porque lo
que no se conoce no existe muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]